Luke bells speaking out tonight about
the shocking day that he lost the
bachelor gig to NIC vile and we have
gotten the perfect person here to get
Luke's story former Bachelorette Ali
Fedotowsky man oh boy
Ali I am glad you are here I'm so happy
to be here and it's a big backward story
day so it's perfect yeah it's a humid
bathra story joy tell me this were you
flipping out like the rest of us when
Nick got picked over Luke yeah I mean I
was I was excited for Nick as he's a
friend of mine but I was so shocked when
Luke wasn't picked and today we are
learning more about why it happened what
is he trying to cast women that he was
already dating I got Luke's side of the
story why do you think that ABC and the
producers ended up going with Nick as
the bachelor do you think it has to do
anything with the fact that these women
might have told them like you were
trying to get them on the show uh I
don't I don't think so at all it's funny
anybody I take a picture with everything
I mean it could be my sister and if
people don't know it's my sister they
think we're dating and it just gets very
um I guess thrown outta proportion
here's how the new loop held drama
started please know that this video is
not made to hurt anyone
this woman Errol Schneider claimed in a
YouTube blog that Luke pursued her
online they met up and he convinced her
to go on The Bachelor I ended up getting
talked into it because I was convinced
that you know it was going to be us into
it I guess it was like after the rose
you were going to meet the next Bachelor
and then it walks out and I'm literally
on the floor like in tears after that
she says Luke disappeared on her the
website reality seed picked up the story
and claimed three weeks later palnet
actual contestant Lauren Hussey and
started dating her so I set the record
completely straight is what reality
Steve wrote about you and these girls
true
there is no truth in it other than yes I
have interacted with these two women we
I've talked to one of them I hated the
other one other than that they tried to
throw you know Jubilee sharp it was
former bachelor contestant from den
season they try to throw her name into
the loop of thinking and I don't even
know where that came from so what about
with Chris Harrison how was your
relationship with him because Chris
actually said that he didn't do your
intentions were necessarily in line with
the what the show wanted we just had our
our questions as to is he really ready
is he sincere about this why do you
think he said that yeah you know I've
had a lot of time to think about that I
didn't have a lot of relationship with
Chris um he stayed pretty distant from
us they were defending their decision to
picnic and um I think that you know if
I'm defending my position as a
production company to pick someone I've
got to have some rationale why the other
guy was not right you know it's just
kind of the can go to response I feel
like so and yeah I know right and what
is next for local I actually asked him
if you can consider doing better in
Paradise I know a lot of us would like
to see him on there
um like he said he's not quite sure he
consider it but he's a little bit heavy
a bachelor brouhaha continued right
[Music]